all right hi there today we're looking
at a neroli plausible model learned
successor representations in partially
observable environments by Esther virtus
and Manish Shani
at this paper is a paper on a topic that
has been interesting me for a while and
that's successor representations so
we'll will dive into all of this the
title is very lengthy and complicated
but ultimately we're dealing with a
setting of reinforcement learning so if
you know something about reinforcement
learning in reinforcement learning
usually you have a agent which you know
let's just say this is you and there is
an environment which is a big black box
that you don't know anything about this
is environment and what the environment
gives you is what's called an
observation so an observation could be
anything but in this case let's just
assume it's a it's you get a little
picture right of what's in front of you
so in front of you might be a tree and
in front of you might be a house and
then you can perform an action a and
this action in this case might be to
enter the house right and then the
environment in the next step it gives
you back a new picture and says oh
you're now inside the house so here is a
door that leads you to this room and the
door that leads to that room and there's
a little table in front of you alright
so there's this it's this just this
cycle of action observation and with
that you're trying to collect some
reward over time now there are different
ways of achieving this this this reward
over time so basically the reward is
going to be for example alright what you
could get a reward for finding the
kitchen or for going as into as many
rooms as possible or you know anything
like this so the the other objective is
to learn a what's called a policy so
which actions to take so action one
action to action 3 given the opposite
relations that maximizes your rewards
there is mainly two ways to go about
this there's the model free and the
model based reinforcement learning
approach let's split them so in the
model free model free approach what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
simply learn a policy and we call this
here PI of s and s is your state and the
state you can think of it as the
observation so in this policy we'll
simply output an action and this this is
the kind of the simple setup of model
free reinforcement learning the
important thing here is you're trying to
learn this usually there's parameters
theta of this policy PI this could be a
neural network and theta R then the
weights of the neural network so you're
trying to learn the neural network such
that if you give it a state it just
outputs the action so you have this
neural network with your state you input
the state into layer layer layer layer
layer and then it outputs one of maybe
three actions go north go south go west
and maybe go east right this could be
for for actions you're just trying to
train the neural network using back prop
and the reward signal through what's
called the reinforced trick or variants
they're off this is model free
reinforcement learning it's very it's
very easy to implement let's say and
it's very applicable and it will simply
give you a mapping you know you have to
know nothing about how the world works
it'll simply tell you at the end if
you're in this state do that action and
the reward will be high in contrast
there is the other world this is the
model-based reinforcement learning
so in model-based reinforcement learning
what you have is a model of the world
and the model of the world let's is best
described for example if you play chess
right so if you play chess and this is a
let's glue a simplified chess board here
four by four and you have a pawn right
here right you have a pawn and
you know if I do the action of moving
the pawn forward I know the pawn will
then be in this square right here
alright in the next time step I know
that because I have a model of the world
and know how the world works and I can
predict basically the results of my
actions so if you have a model based
reinforcement learning setup if you know
how the world works you can do something
like a search so given your here in the
state right you know if I do action one
I go to this state if I do action to I
go to that state and if I do action
three I go to this other state and from
each of the states you can then say ah
but again I have three actions and I can
you know go into these three states go
into these maybe here too and maybe here
I can go into these actually let's do
three as well right and then the
question more becomes can you find a
path through this thing such that at the
end you are in the state that you want
to end up right so for example here is
outside and then here you can go to the
tree to the house or to the field and in
the house you can go to the bedroom the
bathroom or the kitchen and you know all
of this you have a model so you can
actually kind of compute what would
happen if I do something and then search
for the best path whereas in the model
free reinforcement learning approach
what you simply do is you'd say here is
a state then the state is for example I
am in the house and now give me the
action that would maximize my future
reward and you're trying to learn this
directly so it's a very different style
of reinforcement learning basically one
is a one is a pure machine learning
approach and the other one is a search
problem now you can of course mix and
match the two like for example people
and alphago have done they have a
model-based reinforcement learning that
also has kind of learning machine
learning elements but in between we have
the successor features so the successor
representations they are
if you will they are somewhere in
between the two so they kind of trade
off the advantages of model-free where
you you only have to learn a function
right from state to something with the
advantages of model-based the fact that
you actually have a bit of an idea of
how the world works and can adjust
quickly to let's say different reward
structures or things like this so what
do successor representations do
successor representations basically
learn how states are connected and this
is a classic successor representation so
the successor representation M here of
policy PI the policy remember is what
tells you which action you should take
in a given state you you define it as a
connection between state I and state J
and M of Si as J means given that I am
in Si so this could be the kitchen and
your goal is a finding that the bedroom
and if this is the kitchen given that I
am in state si what's the probability
that in the future at some point I will
transition to si right
given that I'm in the kitchen what's the
probability that I'll end up in the
bedroom at some point in the future and
this is formally expressed this is the
expectation over your policy and it's
the it's the indicator function that the
future State
sorry this is the the future State T
plus K they see K goes from 0 to
infinity so for all of the future and s
T is the one you're in now so for any
future state this is equal to SJ
now of course this makes no sense unless
you kind of discount have a discount
factor here so if you're in state if
you're in the bedroom further in the
future then this value would be lower so
that this value is high if you will
transition from si 2 SJ with high
probability
in the near future and this is a
successor representation right it
basically tells you if you want to go
from state si to state SJ how likely is
that in the near future right so if the
if this number is high you know that
that these two states are closely
connected that you can expect to end up
in state as J somewhere down the line if
you're in Si now and one more
representation if you consider the
vector M PI of s I given all of the SJ
some dot here so this is a vector you
can actually compare two states as AI so
if one is if you plug in here you plug
in the kitchen and then also you plug in
the I don't know the garage if they and
he will get out two vectors right you
get two vectors if those vectors are
very similar then you know that if
you're in the kitchen or in the garage
it doesn't matter you're gonna end up
you you have a similar future
trajectories basically however if those
two vectors are far apart you know that
these two states are far apart with
respect to your policy so this is pretty
cool things you can do with successive
representations and I hope this gives
you kind of some insight so another neat
trick is that if you have a value
function so and the value function in
this case there's a simplified
assumption but you don't actually need
it the simplified assumption is that the
reward only depends on the state you're
in basically it doesn't matter how you
get to the state like the actions you
perform if you're in a given state or if
you're in a given room in the house
you'll get some reward like for example
if you find the bedroom then you win
that's a reward that would only be
characterized by the state if that's the
case you can compute the value function
of the reinforcement learning problem
simply by integrating over the over the
successor representations so for
each state you simply go over all of the
possible other states and you ask how
likely am I to go to that state and what
reward will I have in that state and
that's your value function so really
pretty simple you can actually learn the
successor representations by TD learning
by temporal difference learning which is
a method that's not applied for us like
throughout reinforcement learning
especially in thin places like Q
learning and yeah and also for learning
value functions so pretty neat successor
representations this paper then goes
from successive representations of
individual state to successor
representations over continuous space so
right now we all have these states state
kitchen you go to the bedroom you go to
somewhere right and these states were
kind of discrete places so there was a
house and you have different you know
different rooms in the house and you can
go between them now we're dealing more
with continuous states so you can
generalize these successor
representations to continuous state by
considering not the states themselves
but features of the of the state and a
feature in this here you have to kind of
imagine as binary features and the
features
let me give like some really dumb
examples but maybe it helps you like
that one feature could be the smell does
it smell in the room like just binary
does it smell or doesn't it smell right
and then um one feature could there be
is there sunlight and then one feature
could be ah is it warm right with and
these are all binary features and so you
could kind of you have to build the
features such that if the features are
the same then the states should be
fairly
you know close in whatever since so for
example if it smells but there is no
sunlight you're probably somewhere in
the bathroom like where exactly in XY
coordinates you are in the bathroom it
doesn't really matter to this as long as
like the features are high-end so if it
smells and there is no sunlight you're
probably somewhere in the bathroom and
that makes all the states in the
bathroom all the coordinates close
together so this is how you have to
imagine these features you can define
your successor representations exactly
the same over these features except that
the representation is now not from state
I to state J but from a state to a given
feature so that means if I am in state s
T at the current time what is the
probability that in the near future this
feature will be high right so if I am
right now in the or close to the
bathroom let's say the the probability
that smell oh sorry this should be a
highlight the probability that smell is
high in the future is very high right so
this this number would be higher it's
exactly the same except for these
continuous features now and you can do
the same thing
including defining the value function as
a simple linear in multiplication with
these features that is an assumption
under the assumption that the reward is
a linear function of the features of the
states which is the analogous assumption
to saying that the reward only depends
on the state in the linear case or
somewhat of an analogous function not
entirely alright so you can also learn
this by temporal difference learning
exactly the same so this is pretty cool
these these are these successor
representations and you can actually you
know if you learn them you have kind of
a model of how the world works not as
much a model as the model based
reinforce
learning where you know exactly how it
works right here you know exactly how
the world works
have this model in model free you don't
know how the world works at all you
simply know oh if I'm in this state and
do this action that I'll turn out really
well
but in the successor representation
framework you have you have an idea of
what states there are we'll do the
discrete case right now so this could be
kitchen this could be outdoor this could
be bedroom and so you you you have an
idea what states there are and so on and
how they connect to each other like you
say ah from the kitchen I can easily go
to the bedroom but I can not as well go
to maybe the bathroom
from outdoor I can easily go to the
kitchen but I can't go to the bedroom
and so on so you have kind of an idea of
how all of these states connect to each
other and that is the success
representation you can already see how
that helps learning agent a lot if you
introduce the successor if you have
these success representation and what
this this paper deals with in essence is
it says okay these successor
representations are cool but it has only
so far been done in a case where you
have full observability and the full
observability is the case where you kind
of know what state you're in right you
kind of know that sorry
you are in the kitchen you are outdoors
you are in the bedroom that is not known
but what if you don't and I mean most
problems you don't what if you just have
a picture like here right you just see a
tree in the house right
you don't you kind of have to infer that
you are outdoor right and if you're here
you just get this picture of a couple of
doors on the table and you have to infer
that you are now in the living room
alright so in essence there is an
additional layer of complexity not only
do you go from
state from state to state to state but
you don't actually observe the states
what you observe is from each state you
observe what are called observations
right so you only observe these and you
have to infer what they kind of have to
guess what the underlying states are in
order to know what you should do to get
to the next state right you only ever
observe the observations so this here is
the actual thing this is the kitchen and
this here could be a picture of the
kitchen right there's a counter
there's a stove yeah and so you get kind
of what I what I mean in their example
they have they simplify this to kind of
a toy date to set up where you have this
environment and this is this is one
beautiful picture I don't why oh well
just do you have one this setup and this
is this box basically this box and it
has this wall right and then you have an
agent that is able to walk around in
here like with whatever policy the
policy determines how it works right but
then what you observe is not the actual
position but what you observe is for
example for this position you observes a
random point here so they basically add
noise to each observe to each state and
if you're in this state you will observe
one of these points in this circle right
so your your trajectory might look to
you as you observe it much more much
might go for example from here to here
to here to here right and you kind of
have to guess what the underlying state
is and you see this here this this blue
thing is what the agent actually does
but the gray thing is what it observes
and the observations are sometimes even
outside of this above this boundary
and this this orange thing is now the
infer thing and that's what we actually
want is to go from the observed to this
inferred and we want to that the
inferred is as close as possible to this
true latent state right so the way they
do it is they introduced this
distributional distributed coding for
the for the features of basic for the
expectation of the features and
basically what they say is they say we
will build a framework where we can
where we represent the features as as
expectations over some distribution and
the expectation will call mu and mu is
simply the the kind of mean of this of
this feature under this distribution
this is very general so let's look at
what and how to plug this in so what
they now have to do is they have to
learn these two things right they have
to first of all if I draw this picture
again these are the underlying states
and they kind of transition into each
other so this is state 1 state 2 state 3
and with action one action two we
transition from state to state but also
there are these observations observation
1 observation 2 observation 3 so the
agent needs to learn two different
things
first of all it needs to learn given an
observation what state am I probably in
right this is the first thing it needs
to learn and then the second thing it
needs to learn is given this state and
this action what's the next state that I
will go to right and this is a
and this of course these things down
here they're not observed so these
things down here you can only do in
distribution so I'm going to represent
this with a P here you can only kind of
do this in distribution and the way they
handle it is they always maintain the
expected value of these things and
that's they do this in this wake-sleep
algorithm all right so this is Miri
recording this part because I have done
a terrible job at the first time so we
want to understand this wake-sleep
algorithm to compute the things that we
don't know let me draw this actually
again so the way this algorithm does it
is actually pretty cool
has two phases a sleep phase and a wake
face and it alternates between the two
constantly it's kind of like expectation
maximization ultimately what you want to
learn are two different sets of
parameters W and T now you whenever you
learn T you use W the one that you've
already learned and whenever you learn W
you use the T that you've already
learned so it's kind of a bootstrapping
each other up the two functions you
learn here are this F W and the T here
so T is just a matrix and F of W is a
function the function has weights the
weights W so see in the sleep phase you
update W and in the wake phase you
update team now why is this called wake
and sleep it's because in the wake phase
you're actually so called awake and you
use real observations so in the wake
face and I find it easier to start
actually at the wake phase in the wake
phase you collect observations so you
let your agent go around its environment
and collect a bunch of
survey shoes you don't know what the
states are what you do is simply you
collect these observations now it's not
that important what the policy is here
so you basically follow us on policy and
you collect these observations right and
then what you what you say is okay I
have the function f of w and remember
since we're in the wake phase we're
learning T so we assume we already have
the W in in essence in practice we start
out with a random one and write and then
kind of alternate between the two phases
until both get really good but so we
already have a W and we use it to update
team how do we do this this is we need
to understand what this function f of w
does f of w takes this mu and the
current observation and produces a new
mu so what is a mu this this mu here
this mu here as we saw above here the MU
is the expectation over the features and
in essence the MU is a guess the MU is
your best guess of what the features of
the state are or in the in the discrete
case you could also say a guess of what
the state is right so you don't know the
state right but you what you want to
maintain is a distribution over state so
you want to kind of maintain this
distribution but you can't you know
calculate you can't properly efficiently
calculate with an entire distribution
unless you assume it's some sort of
Gaussian or so but what you can do is
you can simply take its mean mu right
and and that's your best guess for what
the state is the state could be anywhere
anywhere here right according to this
distribution but you simply come up with
mu which is your best guess so
the funk
the function f of w it takes in the best
guess of where you were up until the
last step and it also takes as an
argument your current observation and it
gives you the output of F is mu T right
it's the best guess of where you are now
yeah it's pretty so pretty
straightforward if you think about it so
for every for every observation you want
to have kind of a guess of where your
what your state is and that's mu right
so what F does is it takes whatever
observations you had these observations
gave rise to a mu that guess where you
are you take this mu and you take this
observation and from that you derive the
next guess of where you are you just say
I guessed I was at in the kitchen before
now I moved I observed that I move
through some sort of door and there is
some sort of table so given that I get I
thought I was in the kitchen and that I
observe this thing now I'm probably in
the living room that's what f WS so you
input the observations that you had and
you input your current observation right
to get the guess of where you're next
and these are real observations right
and then you simply update T what does T
do T relates your current and your next
guess and that's important we already
said that F takes your your kind of last
guess and gives you the next guess T
does kind of the same thing but he does
it without having without relying on an
additional observation T simply says
well if I am here all right if my guess
is that I am in the kitchen then what's
the probability that in the next step
I'll be in the living room without
observing any
thing right it's t is simply relating
states to each other or relating guesses
of states to each other right it's
simply it's simply saying well under the
current policy that I am what is the
kind of distribution of going from one
room to the next room all right so you
learn in the wake face you learn the T
the T simply represents how you move
from state to state so it's exactly
basically this function here except that
it's not from state to state but it
relates your guess about your guess your
mu of the state 1 to the MU of the state
2 right and then in the sleep phase so
in the sleep phase you you now assume
that you have a good estimate of how the
states relates to each other and what
you can then do is you can actually
sample trajectories and this is why it's
called sleeping it's kind of like
dreaming so given that you have a Model
T of how states transition to each other
or your your guesses about States or
precisely you can now sample state
trajectories so you can dream up how you
would move in an environment right and
the assumption here is that you know the
process that that if you have a state
that gives you an observation for
example in their experiments is always
the state it is X Y coordinates and
that's corrupted by Gaussian noise there
is also ways to learn this transition is
what's called the this is what's called
the observation process right but you
assume you know it so you can sample
trajectories of states and corresponding
observations all right now this is not
the real world but this is using this T
down here you kind of know how or you
kind of have them some sort of model can
learn a model of how you move about the
world so you sample these trajectories
and
from these trajectories you can now
learn the F of W function so you see
since you know what the state is right
you can compute these features exactly
and then you can learn this F of W
function that gives you that takes in
the guess of the last state and the
current observation and gives you the
next the guess of the next state and
that you can then use temporal
difference learning this is always here
also with the T here we have temporal
difference kind of a temp temporal
difference learning to learn the
parameters W so it's very kind of
convoluted but ultimately it's a simple
process in the wake phase you go into
the world and actually collect real
observations right and you have a method
of deriving from these observations
deriving the guesses about the states
and so what you can do is you can learn
a transition between the states right if
you have a good guess of what the state
or given each observation you can learn
how to transition from one state to the
next state except you don't do it in
actual States you do it in guesses about
states then once you have a model of how
you move from one state to the next
state you can go and dream up such state
trajectories right you can dream state
trajectories and therefore also you can
dream how you would observe them and
even that you can learn than a better
function that relates your guess your
guess about a state given the
observation to the actual features of
the state since for this particular
thing you know what the state is so this
this is this two-step process notice the
cool thing we've never actually had
to learn this mu explicitly we never had
to learn how to go from observations to
your guesses about states because we can
compute this recursively right so you
simply start out with mu 0 which is a
guess about the initial state and then
you go to mu 1 and mu 2 and you never
actually have to learn that function all
right all right so that's how they
that's how they kind of learn these
these success representations and the
experiments of this are fairly cool here
is another diagram of how that looks
like you have a state this gives you an
observation and from that you derive a
guess of what this state is right so you
can now look at what the agent learned
the agent actually learns dynamics of
this room it means if you're here you
probably go somewhere right there is no
clear direction but if you're close to
the wall
you're next states are probably going to
be inwards of this wall right and yeah
I've already shown you this picture so
they have a last cool experiment here
where what they do is they specify a
reward and the reward is down here and
from each state you want to know which
way do I have to go to right get the
reward now if they give the agent the
value of the latent state and the latent
state here or just your X Y coordinates
if they give this to the agent and they
let it run they let it learn the
structure of the world it will correctly
conclude aha look these are the kind of
here as high-value states lower lower
lower lower lower value states right up
until over here are the most low value
states because you travel the longest to
go to the reward if you just give it the
observation the noisy observation it
will actually assign high value to
states here because of course it it
doesn't infer the latent state it simply
takes
observation as face valises well I was
here and I reached here pretty quickly
so it must be a good state but in fact
it wasn't here it was here and the added
noise would just corrupt the observation
so you see it learns kind of a wrong
model of the world whereas if you use
this DDC you see sorry about that
if you use this DDC you see you're much
closer to the true state of the world
like to the to the one on the left here
where you so on the left here you
actually kind of cheat right you give it
the actual state but on here you give it
the observation but tell it it's
actually a noisy observation and you use
what this paper proposes and again it
will learn to assign a low value to
these states because it needs to go all
the way around even though it has seen
supposedly seen the agent go from here
to here directly but it it kind of
understands that it's just a noisy
observation alright so this was this
from this paper it's a very very cool
approach I think to reinforcement
learning and there's some more
experiments where you can see that this
BTC actually helps and I'm excited about
successive representations and how to
incorporate them in reinforcement
learning because it seems a perfect kind
of middle ground between model-based and
model free RL alright with that thanks
for listening and bye bye